[موسيقى]
انتقد قاده فصائل ونقابيون وناشطون
فلسطينيون الخطوات التي اعلنها رئيس
الحكومه الفلسطينيه سلام فياض لاحتواء
احتجاجات شعبيه شهدتها الضفه الغربيه على
مدى ايام واعتبروها غير كافيه لارضاء
[موسيقى]
المواطنين
حياكم الله نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش في
عنوانين رئيسيين ما الذي يمكن ان تفعله
الحكومه الفلسطينيه اكثر مما فعلت لاحتواء
الازمه التي تواجهها في الضفه الغربيه
والى اي حد فصل المحتجون بين السلطه
الفلسطينيه وحكومتها وما المدى الذي يمكن
ان تصله
مطالباتهم
[موسيقى]
تحت ضغط شعبي شل الحياه في الضفه الغربيه
او كاد تراجعت الحكومه الفلسطينيه عن
الغالبيه العظمى من حزمه قرارات اقتصاديه
اتخذتها في الايام الماضيه ووجهت بسخط
شعبي عارم بيد ان ردود الفعل الاوليه على
قرارات الحكومه الهادفه الى امتصاص هذا
السخط لا تبدو مشجعه خاصه وان بعض قيادات
السلطه
الفلسطينيه اقروا بعدم كفايه هذه
الاجراءات لارضاء الشارع الفلسطيني الذي
يخشى ان يتجاوز غضبه فياض
وسياساته فلسطينيو الضفه الغربيه يوسعون
حكومه فياض احتجاجا هذه عينه من مظاهرات
غضب قال المشاركون فيها انهم ضاقوا ذرعا
بسياسه الاسعار المشطه والاجور المتدنيه
مته رئيس الوزراء الحالي سلام فياض باثقال
كاهلهم باعباء سياساته التي لم تعد تطاق
من وجهه نظرهم سمع سمع النا سياسات تبنتها
الحكومه الفلسطينيه مطلع ايلول سبتمبر
عمدت بها الى رفع الضريبه بنسبه 1.5 بال
وزياده اسعار مواد اهمها الوقود بنحو دفع
قطاع النقل والمواصلات لشن اضراب يوم
الاثنين شل الحركه في انحاء الضفه الغربيه
بشكل كامل تقريبا وسط سخط شعبي وتبرم طال
شخصيات في السلطه نفسها ابدت تذمرها من
وصول المديونيه العامه الى اربعه مليارات
دولار عدوى الاحتجاج انتقلت الى التدريس
رغم عدم الاعلان عن اي اضراب الا ان
الدروس تعطلت في بعض المؤسسات التربويه
على خلفيه الاحتجاجات المتصاعده ما انظر
بان الامور قد تسير نحو الاسوا طرق جرس
الانذار مسامع السلطه الفلسطينيه فاعلنت
حكومه فياض تراجعها عن رفع اسعار الوقود
وغاز الطهي وتعويض فارق العائد المادي
باقتطاع من الفئات الاكثر رفاه من غيرها
كما اكدت انها ستخفض القيمه المضافه الى
5% كحد ادنى بدايه من الشهر المقبل وصفت
حكومه فياض هذه الاجراءات بالعاج التي
تسعى لتهدئه الخواطر ووعدت باجراء اتصالات
مع الحكومه الفرنسيه تهدف لتعديل اتفاقيه
باريس الملحق الاقتصادي لاتفاقيه اوسلو
الذي عد مجحفا لاسباب بينها ربطه بين
مستوى العيش في اسرائيل والضفه الغربيه
رغم الفرق الواضح بينهما في مستوى الدخل
خطوات اكدت فعاليات سياسيه ونقاب فلسطينيه
انها غير كافيه ولن تقود الى وقف
الاحتجاجات الشعبيه ربيع ما اطل براسه على
الضفه ليضع مصير حكومه سلام فياض على
المحك اذ بات على ذمه تسريبات متضاربه
يؤكد بعضها التمسك بفيا فيما ينقل غيرها
قناعه لدى عباس بان ساعه رحيل حكومه فياض
دقت ليس يؤجلها الى حين سوى العثور على
بديل يناسب المرحله
ودقتها لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من عمان
عزام الاحمد رئيس كتله حركه فتح في المجلس
التشريعي الفلسطيني وعضو اللجنه المركزيه
لحركه فتح من نابلس معنا الدكتور عبد
الستار قاسم استاذ الفكر السياسي بجامعه
النجاح اهلا بكما ابدا معك استاذ عزام
الاحمد انت وصفت معالجات
فياض للازمه بانها غير كافيه ما الذي يمكن
ان تعتبره كافيا
اذا
يبدو اننا ننتظر في انتظار ان تتم معالجه
الصوت في الاتصال مع عمان دكتور عبد
الستار في النهايه هناك واقع يتحرك فيه
فياض الاحتلال من جهه
ومع اسرائيل لاي اموال تدخل الضفه وكذلك
المساعدات
العربيه والدوليه متاخره يعني هذا واقع
معقد يتحرك فيه الرجل يعني هل تتوقعون ان
يملك عصا سحريه مثلا تحل المشكل
ن لا هو حقيقه ليس من الصواب ان نحصر
المساله بالدكتور سلام فياض او في الحكومه
لان المشكله الاقتصاديه والماليه لدينا هي
مشكله بنيويه تركيبيه وموجوده منذ ان قامت
السلطه بل هي موجوده في داخل الاتفاقيات
مع اسرائيل سواء اقتصاديه او سياسيه مثل
هكذا اتفاقيات متوقع ان تضعنا في ازمات
وليس في ازمات فقط وانما في حاله من
الاعتماد على الاخرين مما يؤثر سلبا
وبصوره خطيره جدا على ارادتنا السياسيه
وهذا ما ادى الى هذا الوضع الذي نعيشه
سواء من ناحيه اقتصاديه او ثقافيه او
فكريه او تعليميه او سياسيه الى اخره لان
الوضع الاقتصادي محكوم سلفا باتفاقيات بغض
النظر عن رئيس الوزراء يعني رئيس الوزراء
لا لديه هامش باتخاذ قرارات لكن ليس لديه
هامش باتخاذ قرارات استراتيجيه سواء على
المستوى الاقتصادي او على المستوى السياسي
لانه مقيد مقيد تماما فالمسالة شخصيه يعني
انا طبعا اعتبر انه كل المسؤولين في
الساحه في السلطه الفلسطينيه مقصرون هذا
صحيح لكن اذا اردنا الخروج لا نحمل
المسؤوليه لشخص معين ولكن يبدو على الاقل
ظاهريا حت الان ان الاحتجاجات تركز على
الرجل على فياض
نفسه نعم هذا صحيح هذا صحيح ولهذا انا ارى
انه البعد ليس بعدا وطنيا كاملا وانما فيه
بعد استهلاكي وفيه استهداف شخصي لان
الاحتجاجات حقيقه لم تحصل بصوره جماهيريه
على اتساع المجتمع الفلسطيني وانما بقيت
نخبويا محصوره في عدد من الفصائل محصوره
فصائل يعني هي لم تكن مثلا مثل انتفاضه
عام
1987 خرجت جماهير الناس تحتج وتعترض
وتتظاهر والى اخره وانما حتى الان بقيت
محصوره ولم تتسع جماهيريا ولهذا بدنا نكون
حذرين حقيقه حتى لا نحول المساله على انها
شخصيه وانه اذا غادر سلام فياض سيكون هناك
حل الحل ليس في مغادره شخص ما وانما الحل
في مراجعه ما تم سق من اتفاقيات مع
اسرائيل ومع الدول المانحه والولايات
المتحده الامريكيه بالذ اذا يمكن هذا وقت
مناسب نتقل الى
عزام الاحمد لا ادري اذا كنت تسمعني الان
الان اسمع نعم ممتاز ام اذا اذا كانت
القضيه فيها شخصنا يعني اذا لماذا مثلا
حتى حتى انت شخصيا قلت ان ما يقوم به ما
يقدمه
اي سلام فياض غير
كافي اذا القضيه اكبر من فياض حسب ما يقول
الدكتور عبد
الستار السؤال الي اه تفضل
يعني اولا انا قلت فعلا بعد اجتماع
الحكومه واعلان
قراراتها بالتراجع عن بعض ما اتخذته من
اجراءات انما اتخذ غير كافي وانا اؤكد انه
غير كافي
واتفقنا على متابعه الحوار مع
الحكومه بشكل موضوعي لبحث كيفيه الخروج من
المازق الذي تواجه السلطه الفلسطينيه
وتواجه الشعب الفلسطيني في ظل اعباء
متصاعده نتيجه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وفرض
الهيمنه
الاسرائيليه الكامله على الاقتصاد
الفلسطيني انا مقتنع تماما ونحن كل
الفصائل مقتنعون ان حل جذري لن يكون الا
بازاله الاحتلال كامل ما دام ه هناك
اقتصاد وطني مسلوب كما هو مسلوب الوطن
بكامله لن نستطيع ان نضع مقاييس وطنيه
لفرضها كما نريد اسرائيل تسيطر على سمائنا
يعني ولكن اسمح لي [__] اوقفك هنا يعني كيف
يفسر ان هناك قيادات من فتح نزلت الى
الشارع
وحملت شعارات يرددها عن شخص فياض وايضا
يعني كثير من القاده في فتح بطريقه او
باخرى وجهت لهم اتهامات بانهم وراء تحريك
الشارع ما رايك بهذا يعني هذا غير دقيق
صحيح فتح شاركت
في
الاحتجاجات باعتبار اعضاء فتح وواهم واي
شخص من فتح بده يشارك مثله مثل بقيه
المشاركين من الشعب الفلسطيني اذا كنا
نريد ان نتخلص من سلام فياض كما تدعي بعض
الاشاعات نحن لسنا بحاجه ان ننزل الى
الشارع رئيس ابو مازن هو رئيس حركه فتح
وهو الذي كلف سلام فياض بتشكيل حكومه ووفق
القانون بامكانه ان يقول له ارحل دون ضغط
ولكن المساله اكبر من سلام فياض وانا بقول
سلام فياض اعجز من ان يكون قادر هو او
غيره مهما كان رئيس الوزراء بغض النظر هو
ان يحل الازمات التي نعيشها ولكن خطا
الدكتور سلام فياض
انه خلق امال وهميه للناس منذ ان تسلم
تقلد بعد الانقسام رئاسه الحكومه وكان
سلام فياض يملك الحصى السحريه لرفاهيه
اقتصاديه
وهذا ساهم للاسف الاخ سلاميا فياض به هذا
خطا وبالتالي نحن عن يعني التوقعات كانت
يعني اعلى بكثير مما استطاع ان يقدمه ولكن
في النهايه الشارع لديه مطالب محدده يقول
مثلا لنلغي اتفاقيه باريس ما الذي يمنع
السلطه من الاقدام على هذه الخطوه انا
بقول لك انا انا بعتقد حتى اللي بيدعوا
لالغاء اتفاقيه باريس
والهاء باتفاق باريس مخطئون كثيرا اليوم
اجمعنا كفص رغم انتقادات الكثيره والتي هي
بلا حدود لاتفاقيه باريس علينا ان نرفع
شعارات جذريه حقيقيه لا للاحتلال بكل
تفرعاته وافرازه بما فيها اتفاقيه باريس
التركيز يجب ان يتركز على التخلص من
الاحتلال نريد استقلال وطني استق
سياسي ثم استقلال اقتصا حتى الان حتى الان
الشعارات التي يرفعها الشارع مختلفه
والسؤال هو ما هو المدى الذي يمكن ان تذهب
اليه الاحتجاجات في الضفه الغربيه على
العموم هناك اسئله نريد ان نطرحها في الشق
الثاني ارجو ان تبقوا معنا وسنعود لكم بعد
[موسيقى]
الفاصل اهلا بكم من جديد
الى حلقتنا التي تناقش مدى نجاعه
الاجراءات التي اتخذتها السلطه الفلسطينيه
لاحتواء الاحتجاجات في الضفه الغربيه
دكتور عبد الستار ربما انت والاستاذ عزام
الاحمد تتفقان على ان فياض هو مجرد رئيس
حكومه عينتها السلطه ولكن السؤال هو يعني
كيف تقيم الطريقه التي تعالج بها السلطه
الازمه
الان
شوفي المعالجه الانيه قد تريح الشارع
قليلا لكن لا تنهي الازمات كما قلت انه
المشكله لدينا ثقافيا واقتصاديا وسياسيا
والى اخره هي بنيويه المعنى انه يجب ان
نغير ما نحن فيه تماما واذا كانت لنا
اولويه اللي هي الرفاهيه نستمر بما نحن
فيه ونستمر في سؤال الدول الغربيه والدول
المانحه ب اعطائنا المزيد من المال وهذا
معنى معنى مزيد من الذل مزيد من الهوان
مزيد من التنازلات السياسيه الى اخره واذا
كانت اولويتنا الاستقلال والتحرر فمعنى
ذلك يجب ان نغير ما نع ما نحن فيه وهذا
يعني مزيد من التضحيات يعني بدنا نحط
برامجنا التربويه وفق ارادتنا نحن وليس
وفق اراده الدول المادحه او الامريكيين
يجب ان نخطط اقتصاديا الاقتصاد في مواجهه
الاحتلال ومعنى ذلك ان الاقتصاد الذي نحن
فيه يجب ان يتغير تماما وهذا يعني ايضا
يجب ان نتخلص من الاتفاقيات السياسيه مع
اسرائيل اذا لم نفعل ذلك ونؤكد ارادتنا
السياسيه سنبقى تحت امره الدول المانحه او
اسرائيل او الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
فمعنى ذلك انه ستبقى الازمات قائمه وهذا
لن يحل المشكل ولكن دكتور ه ما تتحدث
عنه
ت يتطلب موقف
موحد اليوم استمعنا الى المؤتمر الصحفي
للدكتور فياض يقول ان الانقسام احد
الاسباب في هذه الازمه ما رايك يعني تحميل
الانقسام لا المسؤوليه هنا لا الانقسام
ليس احد
الاسباب السبب الاساسي هو الاتفاقيات مع
اسرائيل هي التي جزاتنا وقسمتنا وجعلتنا
نفتح ضد بعضنا البعض احنا بنخلص من البنيه
التي حصلت منذ عام
1994 اعتقد انه لن يكون هناك مشاكل فيما
بيننا والصلح او المصالحه ستتم بسهوله
ف الانقسام هو نتيجه وليس
سببا التدهور الاقتصادي واتفاقيه باريس
والتبعيه الاقتصاديه موجوده قبل الانقسام
وقبل فياض وبالتالي يجب ان نعالج الامور
من جذورها لا من مظاهرها لان في ذلك خداع
للذات ولشعبنا الفلسطيني عزام الاحمد هل
ترى اذا الحديث عن الانقسام في هذه
المرحله نوع من الهروب الى
الامام لا لا بختلف تماما مع الدكتور عبد
الستار في ه
المساله العامل الاساسي في في الانقسام هو
مشروع شارون احادي الجانب خطط بذكاء وبخبث
كبير
وغزه حرمتنا الكثير انفصالها الحالي عن
الضفه وحملنا اعباء كبيره صحيح انها حصلت
بعد اتفاق اوسلو وبعد وكلامي واضح قلت
التخلص من الاحتلال وفي ظل الاحتلال الناس
كانت تعاني اكثر من الان و يعني طريق في
67 عدنا عندما قامت السلطه وجدناها كما هي
هي الان اسرائيل تسلب مياهنا تسلب سمائنا
تسلب ارضنا تقطع اوصال ما هو موجود بين
ايدينا تفصل الضفه عن غزه انا بقول
للدكتور عبد الستار بدي اعطيه مثل عن
الانقسام ضريبه المقاصه او حسابات المقاصه
بسبب الانقسام للاسف الاخوه في حماس حرموا
السلطه الفلسطينيه من استلام الفواتير من
غزه على مدار اربع سنوات حوالي مليار
دولار ذهبت الى جيوب اسرائيل ولم نحصل
عليها بسبب عناد حماس وادركت قبل سنه انا
موقفها خاطئ بعد ان حرمتنا من مليار ذهبت
الى اسرائيل فضلت اسرائيل تاخذها و ل هي
احدى نتائج الانقسام نحن هناك عوامل كث
كثيره بسبب الازمه
الاقتصاديه اهمها واساسها الاحتلال
والقضايا الاخرى الثانويه حرماننا من
المساعدات العربيه للاسف اوروبا تقدم لنا
يعني بمعنى اخر السلطه تكاد تتحول الى
مازق فلسطيني ربما اعود الى النقطه التي
اشار اليها الدكتور عبد الستار من اول
الحلقه وكررها اكثر من مره يعني الازمه
البنيويه في السلطه بواقعها الحالي اللي
ربما كثير من الاقلام اليوم تكتب على ان
هناك حاجه لاعاده التفكير في جدوى
استمرارها اصلا ما تعليقك على هذه
النقطه يعني السلطه دائما نحن نقول تنهار
ولا
تحل ربما الازمه
الاقتصاديه احد عناصر انهيار السلطه ربما
اذا حصل
السؤال هل الولايات المتحده واسرائيل
يمارسوا
ضغط حتى واشقاؤه العرب شركاء لهم ام لا من
خلال تقليص المساعدات
وحرمان تقديم المساعدات التي التزموا بها
علما اننا نقول بملئ افواهنا لو انهينا
الاحتلال لسنا بمساعده من احد الا وفق ما
نحدد نحن ليس وفق ما يحدد تحدد الولايات
المتحده واسرائيل والمانحين عموما بس هل
تقدر ان بالنسبه للشارع الان بالنسبه
للشارع وهو يقف وينتظر حلول ويرى ان
اصراركم على التمسك بشخص رجل حتى وان كانت
الامور يعني ليست مرتبطه بهي حتميه نوع من
يعني التعزيز لوجود املاءات خارجيه بطريقه
او
باخرى صدقيني صدقيني القضيه مش قضيه سلام
فياض
ربما انا من
المعارضين منذ البدايه لكل السياسه
الاقتصاديه التي اتبعها الدكتور سلام فياض
ونحن في التشريع اليوم اعلنا في المؤتمر
الصحفي الذي عقدته الفصائل اننا مختلفون
مع الحكومه بالسياسه الاقتصاديه بالسياسه
الماليه بالسياسه الضريبيه وطالبنا قبل
عده اشهر
بعدم اعتماد الرئيس لبعض ال القوانين اذا
ما الذ يبقيها هذا هو السؤال ربما الذي
يطرحه الشارع ايضا ولكن هذه ليست هي
القضيه الاساسيه نحن نتحدث عن حلول جذريه
حلول جذريه ليست تغيير الحكومه من عدمها
انا ب بقول لك من الان مثلا ضريبه
المزارعين كنا نطالب قبل عده اشهر بعدم
سنها اليوم اضطر الدكتور للتراجع عنها
كويس اننا بالضغط جعلناه يتراجع عنها قضيه
النفط هل نحن الذين نحدد اسعار النفط لا
انا اقول من من الجزيره في مرحله من
المراحل الرئيس صدام حسين وافق على
تزويدنا بالنفط مجانا الولايات المتحده
بطريقه او باخرى الان عدتم الى تفاصيل
ربما ابعد بكثير عن الفكره الاساسيه التي
جاءت بها السلطه واريد ان اعود للدكتور
عبد الستار لانه نحن في الدقائق الاخيره
هذه الازمه الب يه التي تحدثت عنها اكثر
من مره اريد ان اسالك ما هي حسابات الربح
نعم
والخساره في استمراريه السلطه في مثل هذه
الظروف من
عدمه شوفي الحقيقه احنا يعني استمراريه
السلطه هذا يعني موضع جدل والمفروض ان
ناخذه بجد اذا كانت السلطه تريد ان تستمر
كما هي عليه الان فمعنى ذلك اننا نسلم
امرنا لغيرنا واذا ا رضنا حقيقه ان السلطه
ذات سياسه او استراتيجيه وتستطيع ان تتخذ
قرارات استراتيجيه باي شان من الشؤون معنى
ذلك نحن نخدع انفسنا ونضلل انفسنا السلطه
لا تستطيع السلطه صاحبه قرار فقط تحت مظله
معينه هذه الم المظله هي التي تمليها
اسرائيل والولايات المتحده الامريكيه هذا
هو الموجود الان نتحدث عن اموال مثلا تاتي
من المقاصه الخلل مش ان والله حماس ضيعت
او ما ضيعت الخلل انه كيف قبلنا بترتيب
مالي تشرف فيه اسرائيل على جزء من هذه
الاموال وبالتالي تتحكم بها عند ما تزعل
منا ما بتصرفها عند ما انه ترضى منا
بتصرفها وهكذا ففي مشكله حقيقيه انه يجب
ان نصر على قرارنا اذا اردنا ان نصر على
القرار فمعنى كل هذه البنيه الاقتصاديه
والسياسيه والثقاف والى اخره يجب ان تتغير
الا اذا كنا عاجزين تماما وبالتالي سلمنا
امرنا لغيرنا ونوهم انفسنا اننا اصحاب
قرار نحن لسنا اصحاب قرار واللي حصل اليوم
انا متاكد من قرارات للحكومه انا متاكد
انه ان الحكومه قد حصلت على وعود بتغطيه
العجز الذي يمكن ان ينجم فقط من اجل تهدئه
الشارع لانه اذا الشارع تفاقمت في هذه
الامور تصبح السلطه في خطر بشكلها الحالي
وبشكلها الحالي لا تخدمنا نحن هي تخدم
مشروع غيرنا ننا بدنا سلطه نقيمها من اجل
مصالحنا دقيقه يعني هذا الح اريد ان اعود
الحل الجذري الذي اشرت اليه يعني ما
تبعاته في هذه
المرحله تبعاته هي تطلب تضحيات والاحتلال
سيكون قاسي والولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ستكون قاسيه وسنجوب المزيد لكن نحن امام
امرين اما نضيع حقوقنا الوطنيه الثابته
لقاء بعض الرفاه المؤقت او نقبل تضحيات
لقاء ان تتحرر ان يتحرر الوطن وتعود لنا
حقوقنا الوطنيه
الثابته عزام الاحمد مستعدون
لهذا بالتاكيد
بالتاكيد يعني نعم نحن مستعدون وعندما لوح
الرئيس ابو مازن منذ اكثر من سنه عندما
جمدت بالكامل عمليه السلام واكثر من مره
قال نريد وجه سؤال للعالم نريد ان نعرف
انفس
هل نحن سلطه
حقيقيه قائمه ام جندي اسرائيلي يتحكم بنا
سؤال كبير حتى العرب
الرسميين حاولوا لج مناه وعملوا على لجمن
لذلك نحن نقول بدات
بوادر ازمه الاحتلال تتجدد من جديد ان
الاوان ان نبحث عن حلول
جذريه والحلول الجذريه لن تكون متوفره الا
بانهاء الاحتلال وانهاء الاحتلال يجب ان
يكون سريع باي طريقه كانت اذا كان المجتمع
الدولي حريص ان لا يكون هناك توتر في
المنطقه عليه ان ينهي الاحتلال باي طريقه
كانت والا نحن مستعدون وانا اتفق مع
الدكتور عبد الستار يجب كفلسطينيين انكون
جاهزين لاقصى الظروف حتى نستطيع ان
نحقق التحرر الكام شكرا لك عزام الاحمد
رئيس كتله حركه فتح في المجلس التشريعي
الفلسطيني كنت معنا من عمان وشكرا جزيلا
للدكتور عبد الستار قاسم استاذ الفكر
السياسي بجامعه النجاح من نابلس وشكرا لكم
مشاهدينا الكرام على
[موسيقى]
متابع
[تصفيق]
ن